Tim way Tim coming up who did you say
who did you say you saved the Bandicoot
you okay now it is go save the Bandicoot
who loves crash get my people I'm just
out to be good Andy let's go candy Andy
Ronon Pausini in who's been loving Andy
Cortez there we go now there's a lot of
people that don't know who I am right
now and that's it's got to meet him he's
fantastic a good feeling all right about
to let all of you ladies and gentlemen
we got something really special for you
right now this is crash bandicoot insane
trilogy we're going to talk about it
I'm Tim Geddes this is Andy Cortese we
have Dan the director of the game and
Jen the head of the carrier's visions
are you ash warped and I was very
excited about it
since then III has happened it's been
launch trailers has been announcements
of Coco being playable in 1 2 & 3 whose
Heights about Coco I am I'm very hot
about ok how are you feeling it's really
exciting to be able to actually now
share all the things that we've been
working on at this yeah could you
couldn't spill the beans exactly of
course I've been seeing a whole bunch of
little Easter eggs and stuff on Twitter
and I'm really really excited about it
hold it if I can spoil a couple things
here seeing these pictures on have
you've seen them what's of everything
you've played uncharted 4 there we go
there we go people it did not clap play
Uncharted 4 yeah what oh there's like
there's a scene of Coco with her laptop
from crash warped and you can see this
scene from a charted for where Nathan
and Elena are playing crash it's
fantastic I love stuff like that yeah no
we buried a lot of Easter eggs in there
so the game has all the original Easter
eggs and obviously now some extra ones
for people to discover yeah I love it
so gen Crash Bandicoot how big of a deal
is it to you that you saved the
Bandicoot you're bringing it back into
all these people's lives
oh my god
it's it's a huge deal just the amount of
love that the fans have for for crash
and it's been 20 years you know since
the first one came out it now's the
perfect time so we thought you know what
a perfect opportunity we're big fans
ourselves so we're so grateful that we
got this incredible opportunity yeah
so cut when's it come out really soon
really really really soon you're
counting down the days it's all my
birthday June 30th so we did is a
special birthday gift oh my god oh you
shouldn't have
oh my god Danny 3 I just saw it all in
don't burn down eat now is it
gluten-free Tim I
is it gluten-free oh I don't know or am
I gonna crash and burn I'll have to find
out eat the cake wish happy birthday
I would make a wish but the wish Arda
came true the Baedeker candle eat I'm
naughty naughty the counter I will take
a bite though Andy how do you feel about
crash bandicoot so I am a what you would
call a fair-weather fan when it comes to
the franchise it was the first game I
played on my ps1 right so I do have fond
memories of it the thing that I'm really
really excited about I came from game
development I came from the up from the
art world seeing the enhanced visuals
how much how much time went into
developing the visuals and like trying
to find the sweet spot of yeah crash
looks really good right now yeah now
that took a long time I mean we pretty
much had to build it rebuild everything
from scratch right and so you know we
got a hold of the original gray meshes
from Sony and that's about all we had to
work with and so a lot of it was just a
iterative process of going over and over
again trying to figure out where that
sweet spot was right and you know we
went back to original concept art we
went back to even the things that
inspired Naughty Dog in the first place
you know Looney Tunes Animaniacs Who
Framed Roger Rabbit because you know the
original game could only take us so far
sure you know and when all else failed
we said you know what we trust our
artists we trust our audio guys we want
you to add your own little stamp to it
awesome awesome now how do you all feel
about nearly giving Tim a heart attack
when the reveal happened and I survived
I survived and now I'm excited now it's
coming now I get to play it
so you're saying three trophies in this
game replied no trophy Platinum yep Ari
Platinum huh pretty exciting pretty
alright so the level I want to play most
I was telling you last time is the Great
Wall of China level yes is that playable
here on the show for it is okay good
everybody yeah when you're done with
this
go play Crash Bandicoot play that level
lobby in the South Hall has basically
the first ten levels from each game
playable so awesome you can play or any
express to your heart's content
great yeah you can eat all the
chumbawamba as you want good good thank
you
not down good luck yeah their mom so I
saw the crash bandicoot himself is here
roaming the floors rings around
he's definitely I hear that the suit is
the original suit from the commercials
is that true or false that's that is not
true actually oh yeah I've been lied to
yeah from the original commercials was
in pretty bad Manit area 20 20 years uh
we actually have it yeah it's just it's
a little old it's okay it's belongs in
museum I say perhaps yeah it doesn't dry
clean very well but I saw him walking
around he has the megaphone and he was
saying all the same catchphrases from
the mercial yeah yeah this attention to
detail is importance and I love I also
saw a Sonic the Hedgehog mascot in a
Mario mascot if we can get those three
together for a picture I feel like
that's gonna be a pretty important
moment that's a paradise right there
yeah yeah it is now can we get crash to
visit to visit our sex dungeon do you
all know about our sex dungeon that's an
interesting segue there are we're
staying at an Airbnb
and it's it's a whole thing there's a
second crash bandicoot should come
through okay so if you give me his
number later yeah yeah here it is
sure yeah so what are you most excited
for now that the game is about to be
released um let's see outside of
vacation um well deserved
yeah I don't know I I'm super excited
for Coco but outside of Coco I think the
thing I'm most excited about is that
we've got you know time trials across
all three games now and we can announce
that time trials also have online
leaderboards support okay so you know
for our hardcore fans the ones who
really just want to you know get the
best times on each of the levels I mean
that's 80 plus levels of leaderboards
hmm yeah that's gonna be a lot of game
play for folks so I'm pretty excited
about that yeah yeah in general it's you
know we've been talking and talking
about crash showing lots of levels
seeing the fans actually get their hands
on the game I think that's what we're
excited to see and yeah and I hope they
can see the the level of love and
attention to detail that the team has
given it yeah so back with the team at
home how had they kind of had it
deal with remaking something that is so
cherished while adding their own flavor
but still staying true to what crash is
it it's a tough balance to strike I
think it really does start with kind of
really knowing the franchise in and out
know the franchise sorta boom oh man
some of these questions are so boring
we're so boring pardon me as I crash oh
this guy oh my god alright I'm
starstruck right now I think there's a
person named Tim here my my is that is
that the handsome area write letters
that's the handsome Tim from everybody
here we all know it's his birthday right
we're gonna give you the biggest happy
birthday it's not gonna be a while I'll
take it cuz that's copyrighted okay so
it's gonna be one big happy birthday for
you okay but with a song like choice are
you guys ready one two three
happy
Oh bring it in
oh my god I love this I love this that
was man now the man hook true man hug
hey you want it you want it you want to
do it yeah I don't know you know the
dance can you teach me the dirt I will
teach you the dance do you guys know the
crash dance do you want to see the crash
dance yeah
all right here goes at all dance right
wait a second do you know a dance ooh I
know the Coco dance you're kidding me
yeah can we have a moment Oh silence I'm
so I'm so glad that you're here
it wasn't awkward this is awkward make
out that was awkward
okay okay dance time are you ready yeah
we're ready all right I'm gonna start it
okay pay attention okay pay attention
all right hey it's gonna start off nice
and slow you're gonna count it 5 4 3 2 1
it's like he's right here yeah that's
him all right guys all right thank you
one more hard believable I get a hug
here come to the South Hall and check me
out because the polygons of the 90s you
know those graphics finished we've been
completely digitally remastered so you
can play the insane trilogy all three
games in absolute HD 4k technology okay
hey guys thank you happy birthday buddy
thank you thank you
I was awesome guys yeah so when he was
doing the dance I I thought I was on
stage I'm sorry that's fine come on bye
crash the dance I thought he was doing I
thought I was watching in-game footage I
was kind of transported the fur came
when I was real really possible the ps4
throw like that I was actually surprised
he knew the dance that was great how was
that was amazing everything about that
that was not planned here at least not
by me nope yeah I mean I guess I'm out
of questions I don't even know god
there's so much happening right now
so here I love it you did you came back
Maya now I don't wanna learn he's eaten
up the card I love it so I have a
question um this is a little bit inside
baseball when you all were making the
three games right yeah did you how are
the two where teams divided up to work
on a game a game a game or was it all
sort of evenly spread out now we worked
on all three games in a row so it was
one team starting with the first one
working all the way to the end but then
you never to really make it a cohesive
package I think you know the team spent
some time figuring out hey there's some
lessons learned that obviously Naughty
Dog had in the second and third games
maybe we should bring some of those
things back to the first so I mean it's
20 years of hindsight really there so
you know like Jen said we developed each
of them in order and then we were able
to take the lessons and the foundation
from each of them and build on top of
the rest kind of like how Naughty Dog
did each of the games have a different
feel to them right when it comes to like
the jump height and like how fast you is
and just all that you know we originally
thought we might unify the jump and so
that would've upset people so we did
that initially and we were like mmm you
know not working
yeah so there were certain things we did
where we did make the jump height in the
first one a lot higher and tuned it down
in the second and the third awesome so
what other changes like getting into it
like what are the things that you did
fix like with crash one in particular so
we really looked at a lot of kind of
quality of life issues first and
foremost I mean there there are things
that you know gamers really just expect
these days like a proper save game
system instead of passwords things like
that so those are pretty obvious ones
but then you know there's there's some
more subtle things as well you know we
wanted to preserve the challenge but
sometimes they weren't communicating the
challenge well enough you know you have
an AI come up and you're not sure how to
defeat it you just die and die again
until you figure out how to defeat it so
we made sure to give certain AI tells
just so yeah ok you know there are
to attack or you know in the case of
even like will take pinstripe as an
example with his tommy gun you know we
found that certain players who were
playing didn't realize that he was
vulnerable in certain periods so we just
added a little more VFX to illustrate
that yeah he was sorry sorry I'm
distracted but Crash Bandicoot is
hugging Shuhei Yoshida right now my
dreams have come true so weird history
good show yeah everyone competing with
any of this I love how excited you that
Koko is playable in all three games cuz
that is a really awesome announcement
yeah super excited yeah Coco is very
iconic big fan favorite you know we
really didn't have time to know we had
any features at all but this really came
from the team they a number of the team
members really wanted to bring her back
into all three level in all three games
and have her playable different team
members would come up to us each week
and pester us yeah they would just do
kind of this hey can we put her in the
schedule no we don't have time but you
guys know what game jams are I hope yep
yep so we did a game jam at some point
those guys just ran off into a corner
and prototype playable Coco and they
came back and they said hey we made
playable Coco it works and I'm like okay
I guess we got to do this got it do it
awesome
awesome so you know at that point we
really then had to figure out what it
took to actually get her into the game
you know so it's no small effort yes we
weren't gonna just risk in crash with
Coco we had to have a whole new set of
animations there's lots of dying in this
game so you want to make sure that
there's some for Coco that are unique to
her custom enemy oh yeah we're on time
outbound okay okay well Dan Jen thank
you so much not only for bringing
crashing same trilogy back into the
world racing but yeah one day one day
but also for being a shooter wish me a
happy birthday and stop my birthday
everything about this I hope everyone
has a happy 3 thank you guys very much
thank you
you